Sau thời gian imang, anh độc mấy đây cùng cấp chi tết về thải nhân sử ở trong chuyện VIX
đoạn, chuyện VIX, trong công nhằm và các cơ sở bị cảo buộc là cùng bố tại Pháp Kista, và khu vực cắt sìa biến dợi hồi đầu tháng 6.
Trong số hơn 1 trong cuối nhân th mạc, có bá phi công được hiện tiêm các rập ali và năm nhân viên bệnh hệ thống phòng không et đúng chăm.
Nơi là lần đầu như đều đi công khai thải trong chuyện VIX.
Lâm dễ lên ghi vàn về hiệu quả của các phụ khí tối tân, màn đất ngại xe yêu.
Trong khi phía n度 vàn đầu khẳng đệ, chuyện dịch dễ dạ chuyện giác và không tổn thất lớn.
Đông thà chào tạo hôn chương sau khi khi xe nhỏ các bình xí đã bột chính phủ và điều chuyện không tin.
Đồ về ra phal y, dòng tâm kích chủ lực giò pháp sản xuất, tổn thất thi công đặt ra con hỏi về việc hiệu xuất thịt bế của mạy này trong tắt chiến,
rù được quả bá là vượt trộ về công nghệ.
Nhất là khi mạy bây này bị bản hả, mở gì mời, tìm kích giò chúng của sản xuất có giá thàn chỉ bằng 1 phần bà.
Bởi e bột chăm, hây thống phòng không tổn thận ngà, cả chế của nằm kích chắc thủ cho thấy hệ thống có thể bị đổi phương khai thác yểm mù,
nhiều khả năng bằng ua vê, bọn tên lượng hành trình.
Ví hợp đồ phủ thuộc phòng ngà trong bảo chì và nân cất, càng khi năng lực phòng thủ đổi không.
Đồ dễ rù gió cao hôn trong bộ cảnh điet chính trị phức tập.
Chỉnh dịch xin đồ từ đó trở thành hồi chung cảnh báo đổi với như thế li về bánh đề hòn liện.
Vô hợp trên thật và cả năng lượng phó hình sẽ lúc các công nghệ của sự hiện đại trong tự chến.